[Music]
foreign
First Look then at what is on the front
pages time to see what is making the
headlines with Matt dathan home Affairs
editor of the times and Jessica elgot
Chief political correspondent of the
Guardian uh both with us from conference
in Birmingham as we can see welcome to
both of you so let us catch up then with
the front pages the financial times
leads with the Tory tax cut U-turn
reporting that the chancellor is now
speeding up his plans to cut public debt
and reassure the markets that his
policies can work the Metro quotes the
Chancellor's speech after that U-turn
with the headline what a day
the star pictures the PM and the
chancellor in a Noddy car with the
headline the lady is for you turning a
parody of the famous Margaret Thatcher
Party Conference speech back in 1980 if
your memory stretches that far
one result of the U-turn according to
the guardian angry Tory MPS are now
plotting to avert any squeeze or welfare
benefits as the government tries to
balance the books that is also the lead
for the I trust faces a new Tory
Rebellion on benefits cuts the paper
says and even the normally
pro-conservative Telegraph says Liz
truss has a battle on her hands to deal
with the benefit cut Rebels
the mirror calling it a Calamity
conference and says regardless of the
u-turn on tax the economic damage is
already done
the male sums it all up with this get a
grip
only the express strikes a positive note
with a call from Liz truss for people to
stick with her and that trust will be
rewarded
and the sun leads with the man who has
appeared in court charged with the
murder of Olivia Pratt Corbell in
Liverpool
were reminded by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front pages
while you watch us so let's return to
our get guests then Matt Dayton and
Jessica Elgar welcome to both of you
goodness so much to talk about and I'm
Keen to hear your thoughts on uh the
mood at conference but um you know first
of all Jessica talk us through you know
what we heard
um you know from from seven o'clock this
morning right through to tonight and uh
the implications of it
yeah but obviously the news started to
trickle out really late last night
um and it was in the in the Sun
newspaper but um it started to trickle
it out into the bars of the Party
Conference you could see the reactions
of Tory MPS in real times you could hear
kind of Yelps across the room and um and
I think you know quite a lot of MPS were
predicting to me over the course the
last few days and property them out as
well but there was they thought a U-turn
was inevitable and every time you saw I
saw started to become convinced of that
you would hear the words of course you
can't say it's just something actually
you know how how can they possibly you
turn now after what they've they've said
it and and yet I think the sort of scale
of the MP's Rebellion became so obvious
by by last night and especially that
intervention first by Michael Gove
um then by grants chaps it seemed to be
you know there was going to be a
constant drum beat of these kind of big
interventions from from the big beast
back on the on the back benches
um throughout the conference you know it
was going to be a clearly a massive
distraction and potentially a really
damaging diff feet in Parliament and
that was why ultimately it was you know
they had they had to make this pretty
humiliating U-turn yes and as we see
from the financial times Matt it doesn't
end there um November the 23rd held up
as the date for this medium fiscal plan
great reveal and the idea is that'll be
brought forward not only that
um possibly he'll have to start
reassuring the markets well he what's
the suggestion
yeah that's right a couple of papers as
well as Jesse's Guardian they're also
reporting that uh they'll um they're
considering accelerating that date so
we're having to wait almost 50 days
before we'd hear uh quasiquiteng's plan
for actually paying for those tax cuts
and the debt reduction plan and that's
um we're hearing that's going to be
brought forward so probably another sort
of if not a U-turn then a bit of a
backtracking in their financial plans
and I think we're going to hear a lot
more about other plans that might have
to be rethought and the benefits
announcement is really going to come
into Focus I think in the next couple of
days where the benefits rise in line
with inflation as Richie sunac announced
or whether they have to
um although there weren't and I think
that's going to cause a massive round in
the party over the next few days and
that will probably dominate
um and I think they may want to take a
lesson from the U-turn this morning and
the quicker you do a U-turn the quicker
you can control it I mean let's not
let's not forget that in budgets we've
often heard u-turns within a week you
know we had the George Osborne capacity
tax we had Philip Hammond u-turning on
the rise to self-employed National
Insurance within a week as well so it's
not unusual it's just the fact that this
is so politically toxic uh 45p uh tax
cut on the rich I think the politics of
this is is much more significant than
those two u-turns yes and if we look at
the newspapers they're kind of split
aren't they reflecting on the U-turn if
you look at the Daily Star Screech the
lady is for you turning
um you know she'd done the the interview
rounds and insisted that she was staying
put with this tax climb land they say
for poundland Thatcher uh the Metro as
well you know picking up on what the
chancellor had said what a day
um what about those comments that he
made you know he talked about you know a
little turbulence and how we needed to
move on and you know this was a
distraction and the suggestion from some
that actually he was a bit complacent
and there was you know a sense of a lack
of Contrition I don't know how it went
down in the hall Jessica
yeah
but I think that the chances of speech
is extraordinary in many ways you know
especially having to announce a U-turn
in three weeks into being in office but
also because the speech didn't really
kind of say anything else there wasn't a
lot you know there was no big
announcement in quasi-kartang's speech a
bit of a a hint at that of deregulation
of some of some areas like planning
agriculture child care which we think
are coming kind of later down the track
but um you know potentially in this next
fiscal event but beyond that not an
awful lot to kind of try and move the
story on and try and get back on the
front foot and you know in some of the
receptions he's been talking at tonight
um he's been he's been pretty kind of
um unashamed about it he's he said you
know we just just came into conflict
with the political reality he's never
said that it's the wrong choice and you
know I think that that's you know an
interesting take that he just you know
he clearly feels and and potentially the
PM does as well that it was it wasn't
actually the wrong decision to to to
abolish the 45p rate he's just been
forced to do it by some restive
colleagues
I mean it's interesting the reaction to
it and to ask Jacob we smog said this
was all about political reality
governments can't keep fighting into a
headwind uh in the telegraph they talked
about it wasn't worth the pain of
keeping it uh one former Minister said
the 45p rate U-turn was
um pretty final for Mrs trust and that
backbenders were now openly calling for
her to to leave Downing Street if we go
on to the other newspapers uh the eye
trust faces a new Tory Rebellion on
benefits carts and has this Matt do you
think given power or a push to those
parliamentarians who don't necessarily
agree with that budget and will we see
rebellions on matters like benefits or
indeed those other issues that
Jennifer's just mentioned deregulation
of planning and environmental controls
for example
oh
absolutely in Boulders emboldism because
they know now that if you push hard
enough and you've got a big enough group
you've got big enough beasts like
Michael Gove and Grant shops fighting
your corner you know that you you've got
that proven track record that you can
force the government to U-turn but it
also emboldens um in ministers inside
the cabinet and inside government to
fight their own Corner privately around
the cabinet table because they know the
the list trust is weaker and we're only
well less than a month into our
Premiership it it took Boris Johnson
probably about a couple of years to
start becoming very weak and considering
they've got um well 76 majority is it
now I can't remember the latest it's
chipping away every every week isn't it
but um given that they've got a 76-seat
majority it's astonishing to think how
weak they are now and just one month
into her Premiership yes so your paper
the guardian Tory plot to Halt benefit
cards after U-turn over top rate tax and
certainly we've seen people like Michael
Gove Grant chaps you know the
cheerleaders in Chief whatever Rebellion
we're seeing now in Parliament but is it
open Warfare one commentator suggested
it was like a hung Parliament or it will
be when they go back Jessica
yeah and I think that you know even
cabinet ministers today would you know
kind of privately expressing some doubt
about the case for
um Landing spending cuts um you know
directly on the poorest in society
especially in a kind of cost of living
crisis
um and I think that there will there
will need to be a really tough argument
made in cabinet let alone
um tutorial MPS and who are openly
saying you know Damien green one of them
today and Esther McVeigh the former work
and pension secretary saying that they
would they would oppose anything that
would that would really hit the the
income of people on benefits and and I
think that that's you know something
that uh a lot you know the way that the
argument has really changed among Tori
MPS and especially the new intake of
Tory MPS
um you know in in this Parliament and
again I think that that's another fight
that that
um Liz truss and quasi quota and are
potentially gearing up for over the next
couple of weeks but it's not only that
MPS are telling us uh in the story
tonight that's on the front that they
also think they've got enough numbers to
kind of really make sure that there's no
frack talking at all there's a big
coordinated effort now to to kind of
push back on that
um and and many of them feeling that
that also will be successful because you
know they've been emboldened by the
U-turn today and even the Daily Mail as
we know have been staunchly behind Liz
truss even they are critical get a grip
is their resounding headline picking up
that screeching late night reversal on
tax policy they'd vowed they'd stick to
um you know all the word coming up it
took place in Liz truss's Suites hotel
room where the mood was Grim etc etc a
threat of new revolt on benefits we've
talked about as trust refuses to rule
out more u-turns despairing Tories tell
the Prime Minister now there is a body
of you know opinion art conference isn't
there uh Matt that believed she should
have stuck to her guns and without doing
so it's now a free-for-all
yeah absolutely we've been talking about
Michael goves and Grant shops of the
Tory party but I was talking to quite a
few of the right-wing conservative back
benchers who are absolutely Furious
Atlas trust and so you've not only
really angered the Richie sunak
supporters and as we said the market
Growers Etc but you've also angered the
right wing of the party uh and and they
say you know never make u-turns in
politics because being wrong is is one
thing but being wrong and weak is is
even worse in politics and they are
Furious I mean I haven't spoken to him
but I imagine people like John Redwood
are very Furious tonight he was um
delighted at the fact that he's finally
got a tax cutting conservative
government and uh within uh within nine
days had already you turned on one of
the main tax cutting principles so there
is disarray across the conservative
party and it's going to be very
difficult now for this trust to pull
that all those divisions back together
in what little over well a little less
than or two years before the next
election now I mean this this will be
unpicked I think for years won't it
Jessica
um you know the impact of all of this
but also you might argue the errors from
these experienced hands you know the
chances of attending a champagne
reception with Bankers on the night of
the budget you know being warned about
unfunded tax cuts and the possible
implications and reaction of the markets
controversial tax cut not shared with
the cabinet as we heard from Liz truss
at the weekend but bigger than that is
the legacy of this not just the high
interest rates for you know homeowners
and businesses for the government itself
but also and I think it was Fraser
Nelson in the telegraph last week he
suggested that interest rates would have
gone up anyway because of inflation and
now they've got a socking great Tory
rosette on them it's as if that you know
it becomes the fault of the conservative
party that they're happening so the
implications of this for their for the
Legacy
um of this despite that U-turn will will
be long lasting won't it
and labor officials are already already
talking about you know a trust premium
on your mortgage and you can expect that
line to to be to be rolled out a lot
over the next over the coming months and
probably into the election campaign and
yeah and I think a lot of a lot of Tory
MPS think that you know it's it's it's
massive own goal and it shows a lot of
political naivety and the quasi-courting
and and let's trust aren't novices I
mean they've been around government for
a long time especially Liz truss has and
but there has been you know so many
basic errors and I think it also kind of
comes back to the fact that she had
reasonably limited support early on in
the in the Tory leadership contest
um you know she was the third choice of
MP it's the third choice of MPS who made
the first choice if that makes sense
um and and even after that even in the
reshuffle there was no kind of attempt
to broaden the tent there was a lot of
people left out in the wilderness and if
you alienate all of those people and
then you do a really difficult budget
and cause kind of lots of damaging
effects and then you U-turn and you also
then alienate the people who've been out
there defending you and essentially made
to look like bugs
um when they've had to you know say say
things you know on on your on your shows
and others and you know it doesn't leave
you with an awful lot of political
Capital left
and what about the impact now on all
those promises that quasi-carto made in
his speech today Matt
um you know promising that they were
serious custodians of the of the fiscal
purse an iron CAD commitment to fiscal
discipline you know even with this tiny
change of the 45p top rate tax cut
there's still more than 40 billion
pounds uncosted so does that mean if you
are Ironclad you have got to bring about
Cuts somewhere
I mean it seems so wouldn't you but um
hopefully we won't have as long as we'd
been expecting to find out but um I mean
I think uh it's only really going to
cause more disrain the party when
they're going to be announcing uh budget
cuts across uh Whitehall and of course
we've already heard they're not going to
be doing a spending review next year
which means that schools and hostages
for example would have to find the pay
Rises for their staff within the
existing budgets so the budgets were
already very stretched and now he's
having to go as you say further and find
40 billion more tax cuts uh spending uh
cuts to to fuel those tax cuts and this
is all based on the premise that those
taxes are going to fuel economic growth
but I think um that is a massive gamble
as we spoke after the the mini budget
and it's going to be fascinating to see
what the obr says in its uh in its
fiscal forecasts um when quasi-containe
brings forward his uh his spending plans
because that is going to be probably
even more damaging than we've heard from
Tory Rebels and from the many budget
analysis because that is going to be
independent economic forecasts telling
us just how bad the government's own
spending and tax plans are going to to
be for you and I and everyone all our
Watchers and listeners so it's going to
be quite a brutal month ahead I think
for the conservative party
Matt Jessica stay there lots more to
discuss on this and other issues uh more
trouble at the top of government why
number 10 may have a squashed rather
some of Jacob Reese mogg's plans uh back
with that in just a moment
foreign
[Music]
with me once again Matt Dayton home
Affairs editor of the times and Jessica
lgot Chief political correspondent of
the Guardian who are both joining us
from the Conservative Party Conference
and Matt we've already talked haven't we
about the the prospect of further
rebellions over some deregulations let's
go to the financial times uh with the
headline number 10 quashes Reese smog's
Half Baked work reforms suggesting that
Liz truss has crushed a series of these
ideas put forward by the business
secretary Jacob Reese smog to radically
reform the labor market
um such as uh introducing no full
dismissal for higher earners repealing
the 48-hour week
Etc so uh what What's the what does the
story tell us
yes please do well this is part of the
edict from number 10 after the mini
budget that they must all come up with
ideas on how to simulate growth and we
heard that massive row about immigration
numbers and we need to increase possibly
some immigration to stimulate economic
growth but this is Jacob Reese mog's
ideas are we here tonight
um as you say uh
um no fault dismissals for people
earning over 50 000 and other measures
such as uh corporate requirements on the
gender pay Gap I'm not really sure how
much that would save and that's
something that we could always growth
but uh I I I don't know um but yeah as
you say the number 10 have come back and
there's a quote I think from a source
saying that Liz truss she's in favor of
deregulation but not quite as far as
Jacob Reese MOG might want to go
yes a number 10 official said there were
limits to trusses enthusiasm for
deregulation I think is the uh from the
financial times
that's for sure yes exactly yes you
wouldn't know so far maybe
um Zoella bravaman um the junior speaker
conference um tomorrow isn't it I think
um considering new laws to make it
easier to deport people who come to the
UK illegally and will call for the
French to stop more boats crossing the
English Channel that perennial as well
that issue and uh James cleverly to the
foreign secretary uh will also be
speaking and one of the other issues on
the front page of the Guardian
um your paper Jessica is about climate
and the Egyptian government host of the
next U.N climate Summit of course has
warned the UK against backtracking from
the global climate agenda in an
intervention prompted by fears over Liz
truss's commitment to Net Zero
um are there real fears that she's
lukewarm on that too
hmm
I think that I think they certainly are
amongst um you know people who have have
been real champions of of Net Zero and
you know they've probably got they've
probably got reason to worry she's she's
obviously ordered some new um
exploration of of oil and gas
um and she said she's not going to
attend
um you know the next climate Summit and
there's this round in the papers over
the weekend about whether uh King
Charles should attend having intended to
go there as as when he was Prince but uh
but obviously uh circumstances have
changed and he he won't be attending but
the Sunday Times reported that she'd
essentially told him not to go something
that number 10 have pushed back on a bit
but um but you know again it's it
obviously those are the things that
raise hackles and you know that's why
we've had this intervention with with
the new hosts of cop27 you know saying
the UK must have backtrack and and Boris
Johnson was seen as a really big kind of
champion of this
um you know across the world a real
believer in the net zero cause and and
obviously Net Zero is also something
that's in legislation but he had
ministers you had Steve Baker who a big
Net Zero skeptic kind of hinting on a
fringe today
um that the only way that you could get
out of the of the Net Zero um
commitments would be to repeal that
legislation I mean I think that that
would be another enormous row which I
would be surprised if if Liz trust
wanted to to go down there but you know
maybe she would see that as a way of
achieving some of her growth aims but I
think that that would cause significant
distress to a lot of MPS okay Jessica uh
Matt both of you thank you very much
indeed thank you